[Music]
[Applause]
hall of famer dale earnhardt jr a
special contributor to the super bowl
festivities two-time daytona 500 winner
he and his wife amy have partnered with
sugarlands to launch their own vodka
brand called high rock i went into the
mail room yesterday and i opened up the
package and i go somebody sent me vodka
i started asking there's no note in
there and i started saying who's sending
me vodka
and then fritzy goes junior is
i said all right well get junior on the
phone you got my attention with uh vodka
there so you and amy are deciding to do
this together
yeah we've been talking to sugarlands
for
several years about trying to figure out
what we could do together they make a
lot of different products from moonshine
to bourbon and
they got a really really cool bourbon
called roaming man that's won a lot of
awards across the country but uh anyhow
they wanted to make a vodka and they
make it all in house right there in
gatlinburg tennessee and they've they
just had a lot of success so we thought
if we're going to do this we want to do
it with
the right people so it's a great product
and we're real proud of it so kind of
starting to launch that
slowly across the country over the next
several months we're going down to
daytona this weekend for the daytona 500
and we've got a lot a few launch parties
down there in daytona
uh tonight and tomorrow night so uh
should be a lot of fun so i think it'll
be uh i think it'll be a pretty good
success what did you drink after you'd
win a race
when i would win a race uh dan
the adrenaline's pumping through your
body no matter where you finished
uh you couldn't go to sleep and
you uh you know so i always went home
and i'd stay up till two three four
o'clock in the morning just trying to
calm down
and uh i drank beer budweiser bud light
i was pretty loyal to budweiser because
they were so great to me early in my
career
and that's what i'd still drink today
and how's the bush products when it
comes to beer
well when you get into the winner's
circle champagne you actually drinking
the champagne or just sprayed on you
you almost feel obligated to take a
drink of it right you like to spray it
everywhere right get it all over the
place but uh
it sort of
involves it it's a great way to
get everyone involved in the celebration
if there's no confetti you want to spray
champagne on everybody
um
but you feel obligated to drink some of
the champagne it's like
baby bad luck if you don't have a drink
of the champagne from the bottle did you
ever screw up the sponsors after you win
and you want to thank everybody
i don't think i ever made a mistake that
i can remember but you often forgot
to
mention your sponsors and they want you
to mention them right every opportunity
every interview if they come up to
interview before the race before
qualifying after anything you've ever
done
uh they want you to mention your spot
sponsors and i was never really good at
that but i kind of got a pass um
uh with with that kind of thing
and we were doing so much
um
uh-oh oh i just saw
i saw your daughter
tell me i
heard oh
i heard the little pitter patter of the
feet coming i'm like okay we're getting
ready to introduce you to nicole let me
let me see her
she took off uh
she's she's she done took off around the
corner but no
i think was it amy who grabbed her
that was tammy tammy tammy helps out
around oh okay
she's your crew chief around the house
let me keep playing straight around here
are our drivers
a maid are you born a driver or you
become a driver
you know i think it depends i think when
you
if your family race like mine did
it's uh it's very you know it's common
to hear people say man you're born into
this and you really are you're you're
you're you you are what you're exposed
to right so if you're born in an
environment you kind of are in fact you
know you're kind of infected with that
passion and
you're you're you're steered
uh to be interested in certain things
that you're exposed to so
if you grew up around racing there's a
race shop in the backyard and there's
race cars around all the time
yeah you're born into it but when you
look at a guy for example i pair my
career kind of paralleled with a guy
named matt kansas and we were pretty
good friends and
he was not born into it racing was
something he discovered and uh you know
he was sort of he didn't have a last
name like me and he didn't have all the
keys to all the doors to unlock and walk
right through
and he was kind of a self-made racer
and had to
learn the craft and
and develop his skills really
from his own experiences and so it just
depends really about you know where you
are and who you are and who you know and
uh what you're exposed to at a very
young age but do you think your
daughters
are going to have that
racing gene
no you know i don't i don't know that i
don't know that you have the the gene i
don't know that there's a uh
there's a certain
real attribute that you can you can be
born with it makes you a great race car
driver i think that
um
[Music]
you know
you just either have it or you don't and
i
you can develop talent but you have to
go out there and you have to drive and
you definitely need people around you
that are helping you understand the
mistakes you're making on the racetrack
and why you need to do certain things
and how to run the line and
and how to get around the track and go
fast
some people i mean it's been the hardest
thing to really
understand
uh you'll you'll see a guy race
and they will be so fast and there's no
explanation for why they're this good uh
like kyle larson for example
right where did his ability come from
this guy can win and and drive anything
on dirt
any type of horsepower any type of car
he seems to excel
kyle bush is the same way
they just have this real
raw ability to connect to the car
and
i always felt like that uh the best way
to describe it was is when you're when
things are working really good you and
the car almost feel like one thing right
you almost it fits you like a glove
and
you
that car is like an extension of you
it's like your arm or your leg you know
how to work it and move it just like
you've been living with it your entire
life
and so um
there's moments uh where you'll see that
in certain drivers and those are the
those are the elite ones though you know
there's guys that are good there's guys
that are pretty decent there's guys that
are talented but then there's this one
little group
that just has something special
that everyone else doesn't have you know
and and it's a rare
once in a generation kind of talent
could you drive any race track is there
a race track you could drive one lap
with your eyes closed
yeah i mean i think
when we raced at dayton and talladega
when you know when you're in the lead of
the draft and you got 40
you know cars behind you uh you're
looking in the mirror you know you're
driving the race car looking out the
windshield but you also look in the
mirror
watching what's going on behind you
probably three quarters of the lap you
might run
almost the whole lap like watching that
mirror
and the the great thing that we develop
as drivers and i think that probably all
athletes
have this ability especially
i would i would assume like a cornerback
in the nfl would have amazing peripheral
vision and they can actually focus on an
object in front of them or a person but
also see other things happening around
them and make adjustments based on what
they see in their peripheral vision and
that's what a race car driver does and
so i can look in the mirror and really
focus on
trying to defend anything that's coming
from behind me uh to maintain the lead
but also as i'm focusing on that i'm
actually still seeing what's out the
windshield in my peripheral vision and
understanding where i'm at on the
racetrack so
yeah it's it's it's a pretty uh
it's a pretty interesting thing when you
think about it but when you do something
for so many years uh you develop those
type of skills he's dale jr he and his
wife amy have partnered with sugarlands
to launch their own vodka brand called
high rock visit highrockvodka.com
how often would you flip somebody off
when you were driving
i um i probably did it that see flipping
somebody off is
it's pretty bad
oh okay
yes well
you know
it's in a race car
you're not able to speak to each other
right i can't i can't cuss you out if
you're in another car and we're banging
and you you did something i'm mad about
i can't cuss you
and so really
flipping you off is
about the only thing i can do to show
you that i'm angry
and well you can bump into somebody well
yeah i could do that yeah
i like i like how that's acceptable but
hey you can bang into my cart just don't
flip me off because then i'm really
going to be i've never i've never really
understood this but i learned this from
guys like rusty wallace and
uh the people that uh you know i i grew
up watching
that for some reason that sets you that
sets them off you know that for some
reason that's a very
um unethical thing to do now
outside the racetrack
by all means you know everybody flipping
everybody off no big deal
um
giving the bird is you know
what you would expect in any other
circumstance but on the racetrack for
some reason uh when you get flipped off
it sends you
into a rage and uh unlike any other
situation
uh and you
you don't want to be flipped off i don't
know why that's such a big deal on the
racetrack for some reason that's super
that's way more offensive
when you're racing a race car to be
flipped off than it is to be flipped off
in any other scenario
i don't really know how to unders you
know how to articulate that or explain
why that's the case but
you're right
your football team is now known as the
commanders junior are you okay with that
it is what it is it's happening right so
i that's not a ringing endorsement are
you well all right so i'll be honest
like i was hoping it would be the
warriors because that sounded like um
easy you know it's easy washington
warriors that was an easy thing to say
i knew that it was probably unlikely
because um
you know somebody's out there
trademarking and copywriting and and you
know trying to you know trying to get a
pile of cash for
the rights to use something like that
and
i have no idea
how they determined or decided on
commanders i don't i was i don't know
how those meetings went uh i was i had
no clue
uh what the name was up until everyone
else found out at the same time
and uh
i don't you know i i think
i wasn't
super in love with it at first but i
wasn't in love with the washington
football team either
when it first came out right and then a
year later here we are going well i'm
kind of okay with that
you know why we just leave leave a
football team that's good well we
weren't thinking that a year ago we
hated it right or two years ago yeah and
so
i you know commanders sounded weird at
first
but i think with each passing day
it gets normalized and it gets okay
right it get and look at i mean when you
really think about it uh you know
looking at all the other teams names i
mean they're not extraordinary there's
nothing you know
there's nothing that really jumps off
the page when you look at all the
they're just names
and
if if they ever came up for sale
yeah would you
be a part of i don't have that kind of
money uh damn oh you don't
no um i mean this is billions of dollars
uh this is gonna take you can be part of
a group
i wouldn't i don't know that i'd be
interested
i don't know that i'd be interested in
that to be honest with you you know i
i it would be such a i would be such a
small fraction of the ownership that it
wouldn't
i don't know what i would get out of
that and and
you know as far as enjoyment and so
forth i love being a fan i want to stand
i want to i want to be in the stands
with all the other fans i want to
wear the merch and i want to
be mad when they lose and i want to
cheer when they win and i want to go to
the you know i want to go to the the we
got there's a guy in charlotte here that
that
uh
has a you know they designate a
washington
commander's bar this is the bar where
you go watch the games this is where all
the washington commander fans are going
to go i want to go do that i don't want
to be in the owner's box and
worried about it how many guys are in
this bar it's you and three other guys
oh there's a lot of people
i haven't wet yet but i've been i
followed this guy on social media and
i've been telling you for a long time
i'm going to come watch the game with
them because i'm i'm i'm a fan i want to
be a fan so
i'm going to i'm going to ride this out
whatever happens with the commanders
going forward i read somewhere on social
media like um
we choose you know when at a very young
age dan we choose this team right that
we're going to follow and we spend the
rest of our lives letting that make us
miserable
and uh
you know no matter what no matter what
happens you stay loyal to that team
right yeah when panthers came into town
i love the panthers i think they're
great i love what they do for the city
of charlotte but it i never contemplated
switching
from washington to to charlotte yeah you
know i had already made that choice to
be a washington uh fan
in 1981 1982 and i'm i got too much
personally invested in that and i've
celebrated too many good times and
suffered through too many bad times to
give it up
well congrats on the vodka safe travels
to uh daytona my best to the family and
uh thanks for joining us as always bud
it's always good to see man thanks for
having me on that's dale jr the uh vodka
is high rock vodka go to
highrockvodka.com